[Music]
you know you've been very forthcoming
with a lot of your challenges over time
you do something that i respect a great
deal which is
not leading with solely the highlight
reel
i think that that's real service to
people who are
suffering as we all are in various ways
often self-inflicted wounds
and i wanted to know if you have perhaps
a favorite
failure and what i mean by that is a
mistake or something at the time that
you viewed as a failure
that in some way set you up for
success later if there's anything that
you gained from tremendously that at the
time seemed like a shortcoming or a
failure or a mistake
i mean the one that that that jumps out
immediately and is is most
relevant to this conversation is um you
know
i was heartbroken when chips didn't
open um because
back to my identity crisis
i had a three year stretch where in my
mind i decided i wasn't an actor anymore
i was a writer director
and i liked that it felt loftier well
and substantively i feel a lot more
pride over having written a script than
having acted i do think it's harder so i
some of it's worth worthwhile but i had
decided i was a writer director and that
was going to be the next 10 years of my
life
chips had tested really high at warner
brothers and they immediately put me on
another movie that i took over from some
other people and so i was doing that
and then overnight that ended i i did
not have that identity anymore
and they had already commissioned chips
too i was already beginning to write
that
and um i got very depressed
like for three four months maybe more
i i started doing math and thinking okay
could i retire now like could i be done
now
if i live on this amount of money blah
blah blah that's
that's what i'm spending most of my time
thinking about is whether i was
completely done
and that's when
i wanted to do the podcast i i
i was ruminating on so much stuff i was
thinking about my own
life and identity and trajectory and the
failure and and then i
i started it in the wake of that and
and um i think because i was so
interested in failure at that time
i say often on the podcast i have
nothing to learn from someone holding a
emmy over their head i just won't i'll
never be holding an emmy over my head
but i can
i can relate if that person cheated on
someone they loved and regretted i can
relate to
the failures that led up to that that
that's something i i can learn from
that's how i learn from people in aaa i
don't ever learn from someone telling
some victory story it's always how they
[ __ ] up and realized it
and so now in hindsight you know
had i had the thing i wanted which was a
being a writer director
it's so time consuming my kids were uh
one in three when i finished that movie
maybe uh
two and four and i would have been gone
i would have taken bigger movies i would
have been
way more into that ironically i would
have ended up making less money
so like this thing that i i had no
desire to do and this this complete
collapse of this identity i had and
desire
um turned out to be something that
allows me to be with my kids a ton i'm
at home all the time
my wife can take work out of town if she
wants i can travel and do this like
this life that came out of this epic
failure this 20-year pursuit
turned out to be something better than i
had even thought to imagine
i didn't even know that this could exist
so
yeah that's that's a very obvious one
for me now that i look back and go like
[ __ ] thank god that thing failed i
would have been writing that movie then
directing that movie then trying to get
them to give me 100 million to do this
one and
but by the way movie business is
collapsing so i would have been doing
all that and
in a time it's almost impossible to do
that so yeah i got
so lucky in that thing not performing
crazy enough
what a story i makes me think of
something a friend of mine said i can't
recall who it was but you know sometimes
you need life to save you from what you
want
oh yeah yeah and then what a great well
even if you go through your own life
right and you think of the times you got
exactly what you wanted
and then the times you didn't get the
thing you wanted and what i know
most is that i don't know what's best
for me uh
the things i got that i wanted did not
turn out or result in anything i had
i had forecasts or dreamt of and yet all
these things i didn't want to do
i didn't want to be on tv i had decided
in my egotistical mind i was a movie
actor i didn't want to be in tv
i reluctantly was on this show
parenthood because i was at a lull in my
career
best experience i've ever had as an
actor opened up the doors for me to act
and so many other things
without question the best thing that
ever could have happened to me as an
actor
and it was the thing i didn't want to do
and you know
i got to do the exact thing i want to do
ride wheelies on motorcycles
in a movie i directed and it [ __ ]
didn't turn out
you